the term deep learning refers to
training neural network sometimes very
large neural networks so what exactly is
in your network in this video let's try
to give you some of the basic intuitions
let's start with a housing price
prediction example let's say you have a
data set with six houses so you know the
size of holders in square feet or square
meters and you know the price of the
house and you want to fit a function to
predict the price of house as a function
of the size so if you're familiar with
linear regression you might say well
let's fit a straight line to the data so
you get a straight line like that but to
be the fancier you might say well we
know that prices can never be negative
right so instead of a straight line fit
will eventually become negative let's
bend the curve here so just ends up zero
here so this thick blue line ends up
being you know your function for
predicting the price of a house as a
function of the size with zero here and
then is a straight line fit so there
right so you can think of this function
that you've just fit to housing prices
as a very simple neural network there's
almost the simplest possible neural
network
let me draw here we have as the input to
the new network the size of the house
which one we call X it goes into this
node this little circle and then it
outputs the price when we call y so this
little circle which is a single neuron
in on your network implements this
function that we drew on the left and
all that the neuron does is it inputs
the size computers linear function takes
a max of 0 and then outputs the
estimated price and by the way in the
neural network literature you see this
function a lot this function which goes
as 0 at some time and it takes off as a
straight line this function is called a
rare loop function which stands for
rectified
Linnea so RDL you then rectify just
means taking a max of 0 which is why you
get a function shape like this you don't
need to worry about regular units for
now but it's just something you see a
game later in this course so if this is
a single neuron neural network
really a tiny little neural network a
larger neural network is then formed by
taking many of these single neurons and
stacking them together so if you think
of this neuron as being you know like a
single Lego break you then get a bigger
neural network by stacking together
many of these Lego bricks let's see an
example let's say that instead of
predicting the price of the house just
from the size you now have other
features you know other things about the
house such as the number of bedrooms
which only write as count bedrooms and
you might think that you know one of the
things that really affects the price of
a house is family size so you know can
just house such a family of three or
family four family of five and it's
really based on the size and square feet
of square meters and the number of
bedrooms that determines whether or not
a house can fit your family's family
size and then maybe you know the zip
code in different countries is called
the postal code right at the house um
and the zip code maybe is a feature that
tells you you know walkability so is
this neighborhood highly walkable you
know being just watch the grocery store
walk to school or do you need to drive
so some people prefer highly walkable
neighborhoods and then the zip code as
well as you know the wealth may be um
tells you right certainly in the United
States but some other countries as well
tells you how good is the school quality
so each of these little circles I'm
drawing can be one of those rare you
rectify learning unions or some other
slightly nonlinear function so that
based on the size and number of bedrooms
you can
family size the zip code as bloaty based
on zip code networks can estimate the
school quality and finally you might
think that well the way people decide
how much they're willing to pay for a
house is they look at the things that
really mattered to them in this case
family size walkability and school
quality and that helps you predict the
price so in this example X is all of
these four inputs and Y is the price to
try to predict and so by stacking
together a few of the single neurons or
the simple predictors we had from the
previous slide we now have a slightly
larger in your network how the magic of
a neural network is that when you
implement it you need to give it just
the input X and the output Y for a
number of examples in your training set
and all these things in the middle they
will figure out by itself so what you
actually implement is this where here
you have a neural network with four
inputs so the upper features might be
the size number of bedrooms the zip code
or postal code and well for the
neighborhood and so given these um input
features the job of the neural network
will be to predict the price Y and
notice also that each of these circles
these we call hidden units in a neural
network that each of them takes as input
all four input features so for example
rather than saying this first node
represents family size and family size
depends only on the features x1 and x2
right instead we're going to say well
neural network you decide whatever you
want just know to be and we'll give you
all for it for features to compute
whatever you want so we say that layers
that is this input layer and this layer
in the middle of the neural nets are
densely connected because every input
feature is connected to every one of
these circles in the middle and the
remarkable thing about neural networks
is that given enough data
about X&Y given enough training examples
with both X&Y
neuro-networks a remarkably good at
freaking out functions that accurately
map from x to y so that's a basic neural
network it turns out that as you build
out your own neural networks you
probably find them to be most useful
most powerful in supervised learning
settings meaning that you're trying to
take an input X and map it to some
output Y like we just saw in the housing
price prediction example in the next
video let's go over some more examples
of supervised learning and some examples
of where you might find your networks to
be incredibly helpful for your
applications as well